What's up?
>> All right. I just wanted to know the
scriptures about um the self-defense.
>> How many do you need to convince you?
>> Uh turn on your mic here, bro.
>> What?
>> Any will do.
>> Okay. Luke 22:35-38.
>> Uh Luke 22.
>> He's going to bring it up for you.
>> Okay.
>> You have it? Open it up. Can you have
it?
>> Yep, I do.
>> I do. Okay.
>> All right. So, read it for me.
>> Okay.
And he said to them, "When I sent you
without money bag, knapsack, and
sandals, did you lack anything?" So they
said nothing. Uh then he said to them,
"But now he who has a money bag, let him
take it. And likewise an abs. And he who
has a sword, let him sell his garment
and buy one.
For I say to you that
>> what's your garment?"
>> To sell it and buy one. By what?
>> Yes, the word.
>> Okay, keep going.
>> All right. 37. For I say to you that
this which is written must still be
accomplished in me, and he was numbered
with the transgressors, for the things
concerning me have an end.
>> So they said, Lord, look here are two
swords. And he said to them, it is
enough.
>> Okay. Now, if you go look at the word,
it's enough. That was 38. You don't need
to go to 39. It means that's sufficient.
That's all you need. That's sufficient
for the task.
>> That's all you need. That is sufficient.
Now, the kind of knives that he's
talking about is more like a dagger,
something that you can carry in a pouch
that you can use to cut food, right? You
know, like cut steak, bread, whatever,
but also to defend yourself in case you
got attacked by highway bandits and
robbers. So what Jesus is saying is the
time is coming where you're going to
have to provide for yourself and defend
yourself. So have all you need for your
journey and have a knife, a dagger, a
sword. This is like it's not a huge
sword, but it's like a dagger.
>> So pretty. So pretty much like a a
kitchen knife.
>> Yeah. Well, I wouldn't say it. I would
say a Rambo knife. Have you seen a Rambo
knife? Not a kitchen.
>> Yeah.
>> No. I see.
>> So you want to get a butter knife to go
out in the street in case dude. What
world do you live in?
What's the color of the sky in your
world?
>> I know it's blue.
>> Are you sure? Because you're saying
kitchen knife. Yeah. So, you carry a
kitchen knife when you're going out,
let's say, in the streets and you know
you're going to get mud.
>> That's true.
>> It's a dagger.
>> Yeah.
>> It It's not a huge sword. It is like the
dagger knife like a Rambo knife. And
last time I checked, you use a Rambo
knife to cut food, right?
>> Yeah. My my my kitchen lives are my
kitchen lives are pretty much uh
>> you scaring me, bro.
>> I don't want to be in your All right.
So, what's his point? His point is while
I was with you, I provided for you, but
the time is coming where I won't be with
you. So, you're going to need to provide
for your travels. Take food, take
clothing, Raymond, and take a dagger to
protect yourself because it was common
back then for highway bandits, robbers
to rob people who were traveling to jump
them, attack them, to steal their
purses, their merchandise, and murder
them, leave them for dead. Do you
remember the story of the Samaritan
>> in Luke 1037? In Luke 10:30-37, Jesus
gives a parable of what a true neighbor
is. And he talks about a man who got
jumped by robbers and beaten and left
for dead.
>> Open up. Are you there, Ed? Luke
10:3037. Or is you're too tired.
>> I can't hear you. Oh, he's got it. He's
got it right here. Luke 10:30-37.
Watch here. Okay. This was a common
way of life back then where people get
jumped. It's like going to shady parts
of the city in Chicago. It would be the
southside, right?
>> The hood pretty much. Okay.
>> And Jesus answered and said, "A certain
man went down from Jews and Jericho and
fell among thieves." See, this is what
he's talking about. When you would
travel from place to place, there would
be thieves and robbers ready to jump
you, beat you, murder you, and steal
your merchandise, your purse, your
clothing, your raignment. So what people
did at that time when they would travel,
they would carry a dagger. A dagger that
they could also use to cut food, bread,
fruit, whatever, but also to defend and
kill someone who was trying to kill them
and rob them. So Jesus says, "Now
provide for yourself food, raignment,
clothing, a money purse, and a dagger to
protect yourself in case you get jumped
and killed." And they go, "Well, we have
two daggers here." He said that's
sufficient. Go back and look at the
Greek. Don't let them deceive you. He's
not saying enough for it. He's saying
that's sufficient. That's all you need
for the task. So here we have from the
Lord permission to carry a weapon to
protect ourselves from being murdered
and mugged and killed.
>> You got it.
>> Yep. I got it. Secondly,
if Jesus was against carrying weapons,
what in the world are the disciples
doing with knives or daggers or swords?
>> You're right.
>> They had them, right?
>> Yeah. You Yeah, you're right.
>> And he never told them, "Get rid of it."
In fact, when Peter took the sword and
cut the high priest servant Malcus' ear
off, you know what Jesus said?
He didn't say, "Throw away your sword."
It goes, "Put it back in its place."
Why would he say, "Put it back in its
place in its sheath." Why not say, "Get
rid of it." Matthew 26:50- 54.
You're right.
>> Yeah. So, don't let these affeminate
sissies tell you, "No, brother, you
don't have a right to defend your
faith." You know, it's okay. Yeah.
Matthew 26 50- 54.
>> Matthew 26
>> 50 to 54. Okay. Watch here.
>> 504. Notice they have a sword with them
because where did Peter get the sword to
cut off the high priest's servants's ear
off?
That means he had it with him, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Now watch. Matthew 26:50-54.
But Jesus said to him, "Friend, why have
you come?" Then they came and laid hands
on Jesus and took him. And suddenly one
of those who were with Jesus stretched
out his hand and drew his sword. So
where did he draw draw his sword from?
>> He sold his garment by one. No, you're
taking it too little. Let me try to bend
and needles.
>> Where did Peter get the sword from?
>> I'm not sure.
>> It's right there. It's in front of you.
Read the verse, buddy.
>> Suddenly, one of those who obey Jesus.
>> Read out loud. Don't just read within
your heart. We don't read hearts.
>> All right.
And suddenly one of those who were with
Jesus stretched out his hand and drew
his sword struck servant. Where did he
get the sword from?
>> From one of the the the guards with um
>> better read it carefully, brother.
>> Where did he get from
>> from the servant of the high priest?
from it. So it was his.
>> He had
>> Why you making it complicated? It's in
front of you, buddy.
>> Yeah, I'm sorry.
>> Because he carried it with him, Emanuel.
>> Yeah, I saw that. I'm sorry.
>> Why you killing me, bro? Why do you want
me to retire from ministry and go
pizzas for the rest of my life?
So if I ask you, where did he get the
sword from?
>> He had it on him already.
>> Ah,
>> yeah. Now,
>> now there's hope. Now you restored my
hope in Protestant believer. I thought
he was hopeless. Now
>> my question to you, you learn. Now you
better understand what you read because
you're not reading carefully. So ask the
spirit to help you understand what you
read. That's why I'm being tough with
you. This is why we end up with heresies
and thousands of churches because people
don't read carefully.
>> Okay.
>> Where did he get the sword from?
>> He had on him already.
>> Okay. So my question, if Jesus is
against having weapons, why are the
apostles traveling with Jesus with
swords with them all these years, why
didn't Jesus had them get rid of the
swords if he was against bearing arms?
>> Yeah. Okay.
>> What's the answer? If for all these
years they're with Jesus and already
they have swords on their own person,
they're carrying swords with them. And
this is something they've been doing
since they've been with Jesus all these
years. Why are they carrying weapons if
Jesus is against carrying weapons?
>> That doesn't make sense.
>> What is the answer?
>> He's not against self-defense.
>> I kiss you, baby.
>> But now Jesus say after Peter and it's
in John 18 9 following John 18 following
where we're told it was Peter. Did then
Peter Jesus say get rid of the sword.
Now watch read now you Emanuel read 51
and 52.
>> Oh let me go back actually I went to
John. It's on the screen. You can read
on screen.
>> Uh then they came and laid hands on
Jesus and took him. Okay. And suddenly
one of those who were with Jesus
stretched out his hand and drew his
sword struck the servant of the high
priest and cut off his ear. But Jesus
said to them, "Put your sword in its
place. For all who take the sword will
perish by the sword.
>> Did he say get rid of your swords? Throw
them away.
>> No, he said put them away.
>> Put them where? What's the wording?
>> Put your uh put your sword in its place.
>> So where was he supposed to put the
sword?
>> Back in his uh his ways where he had it.
>> Ah why did he say get rid of it?
>> Why didn't he say get rid of your
weapons, dude? You're my followers.
You're not supposed to be put it back in
its place. Put it back in its sheath.
>> So why is he allowing them to carry
swords
>> if Jesus is against bearing arms?
>> Yes. For protection. Okay.
>> You got it now.
>> Yeah.
>> Now I rocked your foundation and scared
literally that the kingdom in you. Now
you know when I come on I better read
carefully.
>> Yeah. Very okay, Sam. Thank you.
>> You got it now. So now what I need you
to do is buy you some weapons. Come live
in my neighborhood because you're going
to now
>> you're going to now protect me. Buy some
weapons. Come be my next door neighbor
because when someone messes with me, I'm
going to say, "Hey, Emanuel, you know
what's what to do. Roll up on this
brother."
>> Okay. Thank you,
>> brother. God bless you. I hope you were
blessed and challenged and scared.
>> Yeah. Thank you, son. God bless you.
>> God bless you, brother. Right.